hi everyone and welcome to this
JavaScript tutorial to create the 1979
Atari game asteroids or our version of
it at least in this first part of the
tutorial we're going to create the ship
and make it move around the screen and
everything so you go around go ahead and
download this template if you like
update the title to whatever you like
asteroids we're going to use HTML canvas
to achieve our graphical display so give
it an ID game canvas or similar give it
a width width will equal say 700 hi you
can change this to whatever you like
height will equal 500 first of all we
need to grab that canvas just from
experience I know that we need to give
this a jar ajs doc so at type just so
that it recognizes as a canvas element
so at type curly braces HTML canvas
element close the j/s dock and move to
mm-hmm then we can create the variable
cans and that will equal the document
get element by ID and just type in the
string that we had up there the ID came
canvas great get rid of this we need to
get the context from the canvas so the
context will equal the canvas get
context and it's going to be of type 2d
good we also need to set up the game
loop to achieve our animation we can
just use the inbuilt function set
interval for that it requires a handler
so that's just the function name update
and a timeout in milliseconds so 1000
divided by our framerate so we'll set up
a constant called fps
const FPS equals 30 frames per second
same so that'll be will this leave a
note frames/second
so that means it'll call this update
function once every thirtieth one
thirtieth of a second so let's go ahead
and create that function update function
update what will we do first in this
well we need to draw let's plot out what
we're going to do in this tutorial so
we'll draw the background or draw space
we will draw our ship we will what else
we will move the ship move or rotate the
ship first doesn't really matter the
order here we'll move the ship move the
ship dropship draw space good ok so
first of all we need to draw space how
do we do that well we can just set up
the fill style basically we'll just
paint the background in black so if your
style will equal black and we'll draw a
rectangle draw so fill rectangle is to
draw a filled rectangle obviously it
requires the origin which is this going
to be zero zero and the width will which
will be the canvas with canvas width and
the height is the canvas height let's
just run that make sure that it's
working okay there we go that's the
background great next we want to draw a
ship now how are we going to represent
our ship probably the best way is just
by using a we can describe a variable
called ship using an object a JavaScript
object well that is is a fancy array
really
so ship will equal curly braces now we
put all our properties in here so what
do we need to know about our ship we
need to know the x coordinate so let's
start it in the center of the page
center of the ship center of the ship
center of the screen so that'll be
canvas
with / - the Y component will be the
canvas height / - what else do we need
to know the ship size so have a radius R
that represents radius it'll be based on
how about we set up a constant here
constant ship size which will equal
let's put it in pixels say 30 ship size
or ship height maybe ship height in
pixels you could make this a percentage
of screen width if you wanted to or
screen height but I'll just keep it as a
fixed number so the radius will be half
of that liner ship size divided by 2 we
also need to know the direction of the
ship for heading as such I'll call that
a for angle now if you know your
trigonometry and the unit circle zero
degrees is facing right facing upwards
is 90 degrees so we'll predict 90
degrees but all the math functions don't
work in degrees they work in radians so
we have to convert this to convert this
to radians by doing divided by 180 and
multiplying by math PI / 1 e times I
don't need that convert to radians okay
so we have an angle to draw that ship
well we need to set up our context first
set up the colors and so on so we'll
have it as a stroke a stroke style we'll
just make it white we will maybe set the
line width we'll set the line width how
about we put that as a percentage of the
ship size so that will be say ship size
say / 20 good
now the actual ship to draw a triangle
so this is going to be draw triangular
triangular ship draw a triangular ship
so to draw a triangle we need to use
the path so we can do a beginning path
just call that function begin path and
we need to move the cursor to where we
want to start so we'd use we use the
function move - it just takes an x and y
component x and y coordinate so the x
coordinate will be the x of the ship
planet well that'll the X of the ship
represents the center of the ship so we
want to add something to that now what
do we add again some trigonometry we
just need to add the radius sorry the
ship radius ship radius multiplied by
the cosine because cosine represents the
horizontal of the ships angle whatever
that angle might be right similarly we
the Y component will be the radius times
the sine so that's the vertical of these
ships angle we can test this yeah I
actually will have to draw a line first
so that's the tip of the ship so that's
the tip that nose I guess and then nose
of the ship now we'd like to move to the
the rear left of the ship so remember
it's a triangle so context will do a
line too so it'll draw a line from the
original point from the two where well
the rear of the ship we could use that
to represent the rear of the ship just
with one minor change instead of ah
sorry I just made a mistake here ship Y
should be - the ship - the route that
because- represents upwards on the
screen all right now to get this sum to
get the rear of the ship we would change
the sign so change the plus to a minus
in the - tool + so this will be the rear
left of the ship now that's the rear
center that we currently have so we need
to modify this I just grabbed out a
scrap piece of paper before and worked
all this out using trigonometry so
you can either do it yourself or just
trust me we need to add the sign of the
ships angle here alright and here we
just need to subtract the cosign of the
ships angle I'm not going to explain the
maths here I don't really want to do a
math lesson alright so that should draw
the real F now since this we can just
use context stroke that means it'll draw
the path let's have a look what that
looks like that's looking good do
something similar so copy and paste this
this is going to be the rear right so
we're going to draw a line to the rear
right now in order to do that it's the
same thing except all we have to do is
change the sign in here pretty simple
let's have a look at that yep it's drawn
the rear of the triangle and finally we
want to finish off we want to close this
see there is an inbuilt command I think
it's called
closed closed path there we go and that
should complete the triangle for us
great read the test the angles though
don't mean so go back up to the ships
angle China is it a 90 change it to save
55 so it should be facing right on an
angle cool
how about 155 that should be the face in
the other direction looking good and
we'll go back to our original looks like
it's working well great I'm just
thinking we should probably put the
center of the triangle in just for our
testing purposes so well down here
Center dot we can do that just by
setting up a context fill style
which will be say red doesn't matter
what color and we'll draw a rectangle so
filled rectangle the origin will be the
center of the ship so ship dot X minus 1
so we'll make it say 2 pixels wide the
ship dot y -1 and the size will be 2 - 2
pixels by 2 pixels let's just see if
that's there okay yep so that's exactly
how we've programmed that the center
will be exactly 1 radius from the peak
and 1 radius from the bottom but that's
not really the center of a triangle when
we rotate this ship it might not look
very nice so we could the actual
centroid have a triangle is a bit below
that it's 2/3 from its peak I think so
we can fix that up pretty simply so 2/3
which needs up the nose that should be
1/3 a head so we'll go for time 4/3
times that so 4/3 times that and this
will be 4/3 times that I think yeah
remembering this is all in the rake this
is the radius of the ship so that's why
we're using four thirds here the rear we
just need to multiply the first
component by 2/3 to get this working I
think 2/3 yep
so this first component of each of these
just multiplied by 2016 and that's
actually the centroid of a so if you
draw a line from this vertex to the
center of that side that's how you work
out anyway you don't need to know the
math that's where the center of the
triangle would be a much nicer
experience good so how do we go about
rotating this ship well we've got an
angle we need to update the angle when
they push a button say push the left
arrow key so we will need to set up some
what do they call them event handler set
up event handlers so we can do that just
by going document ad is it add event
listener add event listener it requires
a type so the type is one of these here
it's actually the one we're looking for
is key down so when that means it'll
detect when one of the keyboard keys are
pressed and the listener well that'll be
the function recall so we'll just call
that key down the same thing really when
we push the left key we want to rotate
left when we unleash the key that means
when we release the key I guess we also
need to capture that event so we can
just duplicate that and use the key up
okay yep so that detects when the key
has come up and we'll make a function
called key up right so let's do that
function key down it will take an event
as a parameter so we can just use our
today stock again just to make sure it's
very clear that it's an event and at
type I think it's all keyboard yet
keyboard event is there keyboard event
keyboard event oops we need that in
braces and then we just can so look at
that again they just call it DV so we
can do the same thing Evie
right now we don't want any key to do
something do it we don't want them to
push the six or the question mark and
something happens unless you want to
program it that way but we just want to
detect arrow keys so to do that we can
make a switch statement switch
oops I didn't close this there we go
so it's event.keycode so that'll detect
the key code the actual code of the key
that's pressed the arrow keys are what
we're interested in
so they're actually they start at number
37 I believe so it's the 37 for left 38
for up 39 for right that's all we need
to know I think so we can go case 37 I
don't want to add eventlistener we'll
break that and repeat this for each of
the key codes that will be using so
we'll be using 38 will be using 39 and
just probably the right note here so
this is the left arrow and in brackets
what do we want it to do we want it to
rotate ship left okay similarly we want
39 37 39 is it the right numbers I think
so rotate ship right will soon work here
whether it's right or not this will be
the right arrow 38 that's the up the up
arrow and what will that do that will
what's the term for shooting and thrust
thrusts the ship forward
okay let's we'll do that later so first
of all how are we going to handle this
so we push the left arrow something
happens how about we set the rotation of
the ship so in order to do that we'll
have to give another property we can
just call it our ot for a rotation it's
currently equal to zero we don't want
any rotation we should probably set up a
rotation speed here for return speed
what if you want to call it constant
turn speed and we'll set it in say
degrees per second so I'll set it to say
360 and this is turn speed in degrees
second okay so when the left hour is
pushed we want to update the ship's
rotation it will equal the turn speed
now that's in degrees so we have to
divide to get radians we have to divide
by 180 times by math PI and this will be
we want to get the per frame speed don't
we so what to divide by the frame rate
otherwise it'll be rotating way too fast
first in milliliters copy and paste set
put that in the right there we go this
one must be the negative of that won't
it so we can set the rotation when the
right arrow is pushed 'fl to set the
rotation to the negative of that now
that won't do anything yet because we
need to do something with this rotation
so down where we've marked rotate ship
all we have to do is ship dot angle plus
equals should this be okay should be
ship angle plus equals the row the
ship's rotation ship dot rotation I
think that should do it
let's give it a go something's gone
wrong ship stroke plus equals the ship's
rotation probably we can open up a
console here to see the error what does
it say reference key up is not defined
okay so would it wants to see all these
functions written first so function key
up it doesn't do anything yet although
actually let's try we might as well put
this in now it's copy and paste the same
thing so 37 left arrow we want to
stop rotating so when the key is
released we want to stop rotating left
this will be stopped
thrust stop thrusting and this will be
row stop stop rotating right okay now
what we have to do here is instead of
setting a speed we just set up to zero
so there will be no rotation right now
let's try that again and reload there we
go
now if I push the left arrow yeah okay
something's not it's rotating the
correct direction so when I push left
it's rotating and it pushed right it's
rotating that's fine but it's not
stopping so something is going wrong
here
I see we in our key up we haven't put
the event silly isn't it there we go so
the key up will detect an event now
let's try that
so left release the key right release
the key yeah our rotation is working
well but nothing else is happening we
can't thrust at this point so how about
we work on that can you see the the
center of the triangle is more accurate
if you put it at the front of the ship
how we had it would look a bit funny so
we used its centroid so thrusting how
we're going to handle that well I'd like
to give you some more parameters some
more properties to our ship so how about
we say we just put a flag in here called
thrusting so that's just a true/false
abilene and we'll say it's not thrusting
to being with and then we'll also have
the thrust magnitude so it can be simply
it can have its own component the X
component which will be 0 to begin with
and the Y component which will also be
zero so we can set the thrust magnitude
this allows us to when we thrust in one
direction and we release the key the
ship will continue in that direction
even if we rotate it will continue in
that direction
okay so up arrow thrust the ship truss
the ship forward so first all we want to
do in this actually when they push the
up arrow all that we'll do is set that
thrusting to true that's all what we'll
do
similarly when they release the arrow it
will set the thrusting to false
great but where we going to thrust this
ship well fix it put the thrust here
before drawing it because we'll probably
want to put a little graphical display
as well that'll be behind the ship not
trust the ship we want to thrust the
ship okay so to do that we just need a
stopper if ship thrusting so if the ship
is thrusting we want to do something
don't mean we want to increase the
thrust so to do that we can discuss it
dot thrust now the extra component we
want to add to it as long as we're
thrusting we're gonna add the thrust so
we'll probably need a base thrust up
here so how about the let's call it ship
thrust we'll set it to something say
five make this an acceleration so this
is acceleration of the ship in pixels
per second per second a bit a little bit
of physics for you so the ship thrust
equals five so that means in the first
second I'll go five pixels in the second
second it'll go 10 pixels the third
second 15 pixels and so on till we get
faster and faster as long as you're
holding that key
so this your thrust will equal the ship
throw so the ship thrust x-component
will equal the ship thrust all right
multiplied by the cosine because it's
going to be the X component the cosine
of the ship's angle similarly the Y will
just be the sine component let's see if
that works
I am we haven't moved the ship yet so
it's updating the thrust component but
we have to use that thrust in order to
move the ship so what we need to do is
the ship X will plus equals the ship's
thrust X and the y component will plus
equal the ship's thrust y component so
this will means it'll keep moving as
long as we're thrusting that way or as
even if when we release the key it
should keep moving let's try it I'm
pushing the up key whoo I know what I've
done wrong first of all we got the wrong
direction right so in this ship thrust
that'll be minus equals minus equals the
X no the Y component sorry so it's going
the Y component should be minus equals
and we haven't accounted for the frame
rate so just divide all this by the
frame rate frames per second frames per
second okay let's try that
pushing up yep so I've pushed up now I
can't pull back I don't want it you have
to turn the ship in order to thrust it
backwards so turn the ship that way to
stop going that way after thrust that
way thrust that way probably will want
some sort of frictional component I know
depending where you are in space there's
not in a much friction but that's for
this game I think we should have some
friction otherwise you'll forever zoom
that way and never slow down so to do
that what do we need to do let's add a
friction constant constant friction
friction now usually friction
coefficients in physics or whatever
value between zero and one so we'll set
it up to say be point seven and we'll
define that as friction coefficient of
space where zero equals no friction one
equals lots of friction you can have
typically you can have a frictional a
friction coefficient above one but what
is six of this so point seven now how do
we apply that so somewhere in our thrust
so thruster ship somewhere in here we
need to apply the friction no so when
it's thrusting we want it to go forward
otherwise so that means that they're not
pushing the thrust key they're not
pushing upwards when it's when it's not
thrusting the friction will take hold so
to do that we can just ship dot thrust X
now we just want to reduce this by a
factor of itself so we can just do
friction times remember it's an up value
between zero and one so it'll get
smaller times the ships thrust so by
itself the X component of the thrust and
we need to divide that by the framerate
right do the same thing for the Y
component except change that to Y I
think that should do it so it should
apply this frictional component every
frame and slowly slow down the ship
let's try it so I'll push forward a
little bit let go and it's slowing down
go that way let go
yeah that look seems about right so I
can turn around I'm holding the arrow
key while I'm turning here then I'll
release it when I'm going on an angle
say and it's slowing down
great the friction is working well now
in the actual game I think you can fly
off the screen so if I fly off the top
of the stream I'll pop back on to the
bottom so how are we going to do that
so we can handle the edge of the strange
Southwest moon handle edge of screen so
we need to detect when that happens
first so if the ship's X component if
the ship X is less than zero - the
ship's radius either way we want to set
the ship's X to where we want to set it
to the right of screen don't we so it'll
be the canvas width plus the ship's
radius right else if the ship X is
greater than basically greater than this
here so it's greater than the width of
the screen plus the radius of the ship
we want to set it to this part zero
minus the radius all right that's for
the X component for the Y component just
need to change all of this - why why why
why and use height instead height
instead let's give it a go
so thrusting thrusting upwards turning a
little bit yeah pop back on the screen
there will it go this way yes going back
here reverse direction
do you mean that way yeah well maybe
fast slow down a bit seems to be working
well great
okay that's al I was just thinking when
we're thrusting this ship maybe we want
to add a bit of a graphic like a bit of
a thruster like a bit of flame or
something so to do that we're we're
thrusting the ship we'll just need to
draw something here so draw the
thruster right so the thrust will be a
triangle so we'll just copy and paste
this one just get that indenting
indentation there we go
what strike style we're gonna have well
I'm thinking yellow and we'll probably
have a fuel as well put a comma there
that's not right let's change that it's
amazing it's working okay though we'll
have a fill style as well so that'll be
the interior the flame as such a fill
style will equal red you can customize
these colors how you like the line with
probably bit thicker so we'll make it
1/10 so the ship size divided by 10
beginpath the nose of the ship it's not
wet we don't want to we want to thrust
behind the ship so to do that we need to
change this to a negative change is
still positive now that'll be the center
of the ship actually copy and paste this
second pass we'll start at the rear left
first so we'll start at the rear left
paste that in there so move to so this
will be the rear left we want a line to
the rear center which is behind the ship
so this will be behind the ship behind
the ship okay so that's all correct
except that we're going to be do it
behind so don't throw up behind we just
need to multiply one time step by two or
make it four thirds we don't need this
here because it's for Center so we need
to get rid of that so lots of confusing
maths I know
so let's be the cause in the sign and
four thirds of it to be behind the ship
so maybe times like eight thirds there
you go that'll be twice as the length of
the ship behind this so near center
behind the ship rear center behind the
ship now the rear left that's correct
except that we want we'll see what that
looks like first now we need to also
draw the fill here so the context fill
let's try it now we're not thrust whoa
that's huge isn't it maybe it's a bit
too huge
let's bring the triangle in a little bit
so to do that we can if first of all
it's too far behind it so we'll change
it to six thirds say now to get it a bit
thinner we could just put a multiply in
here so your point five multiplier in
each of these the left component the
rear left and the rear right so
hopefully that'll bring in the let's try
yeah that's looking pretty good you can
make your own sound effects we probably
will add sound effects later that looks
pretty cool you can adjust the size of
it how you wish maybe you could just go
with four thirds here what will that
look like
bit too small isn't it depends what you
like I'll put it back to six thirds
sounds good
great that's the thruster is there
anything else we need to do here I think
we're pretty much they don't reload that
I think we're done for this tutorial you
can turn off the center dot just need to
whereas the center dot here we go just
stop drawing this
and we have our asteroids ship that can
go around and around thrusting along
we're going to create the asteroids
themselves that float around the ship in
space so currently this is what our game
does we have a little ship that flies
around the screen wouldn't it be nice to
have some asteroids floating around it
so here's our code you can go ahead and
download this from the link below so the
first step would be to set up our
asteroids variable so just underneath
where we set up our ship we can create
how about we set up asteroids so that'll
just be a variable we'll call it roids
just to keep it short roids equals a
blank array and how about we create a
function called create asteroid belt
because during the game we'll probably
have to call this a couple of times as
we reset the screen and so on great
asteroid belt that'll do so go down and
create set that up somewhere here we go
function create asteroid belt now what
does it do the first step is to clear
our clear our roids array roids will
equal that so just clearing it because
it may be populated during game secondly
how we want to loop over the number of
asteroids that will be creating don't we
so we could use a loop for that for so
for VAR i equals 0 i is less than less
than what how about we create a constant
so at the top just create a constant
well prefix all these by roids
yeah roids num and we'll say there's
three of them so this is the starting
number of asteroids I say starting
because as the difficulty increases will
probably be increasing this as the level
goes up roids num so I is less than
roids num i plus plus so that'll loop
over all the asteroids now we want to
add roids
push that'll be add something to our
right now that we create a function
called new asteroid again we'll probably
need this for later on new asteroid yeah
we'll try that
so we'll go make that down here function
new asteroid we can create a variable
called roid it's going to be an object
and we'll return that object return roid
now what do we need to know for each
asteroid well we need to know an XY
coordinate I think we should pass the x
and y components because later on in the
game we'll need to know the exact
location so X will equal X Y will equal
Y we'll need to know an X velocity which
is going to be some random random
velocity how about we set up a constant
soon for roids speed and we'll have to
divide that by the frame rate we also
want to random direction not only do we
want to random magnitude we want to
random direction so to achieve that we
can go math.random if math.random is
less than 0.5 then multiplied by 1 so
it'll go in a positive direction else
multiplied by a minus 1 it'll go in a
negative direction we can just copy and
paste that for the Y component as well
we'll also want to know the radius of
each asteroid it will change as we shoot
them later on and that will just be
based on some roids
size divided by 2 and we also want to
know in a random angle so this has to be
in this has to be in radians so
math.random times math.pi times 2 which
is the same as 360 degrees so this will
be in radians so let's go ahead and
create these size and speed roids size
and speed up here
so roids size will be let's say 100 so
this will be the starts maximum starting
size now we'll say the starting size of
asteroids in pixels okay
Android speed I'm just taking some
guesses here about what sort of speed we
want put pixels per second so this will
be the max starting speed not pede speed
of asteroids in pixels per second okay
so it's starting size of asteroids in
pixels is 100 and the start the max
starting speed of asteroids in pixels
per second which is 50 pixels per second
that looks good because we're passing x
and y we'll have to go and modify our
call up here so there'll be some x and y
value that we'll put through there now
what's that going to be we can just
create two variables here var x and y
how about we just create two random
positions on the on the screen so
that'll just be math.random times by
canvas width canvas top width we'll
probably want to round that down math
for law and do a similar thing for the Y
direction except that we'll be using
height I can think of one problem here
we're potentially going to have
asteroids landing on the ship
we'll handle that soon right now let's
go down to the update function so where
we draw our ship
let's after that will draw the asteroids
so we'll have to loop through each of
the asteroids in order to achieve this
so far I equals zero I is less than the
roids roids dot length make this just a
property I think and I plus plus
first of all let's set up the color of
the asteroids strikes tile equal I look
at this color up before slate gray just
to get them a bit of a different color
from the ship and we also need to set
the line width line width will equal we
can base it off ship sighs I think ship
size divided by 20 now let's plot out
what we're gonna do here how are we
going to draw these things well I think
we need to draw a path through a path
what shape are they gonna be probably a
polygon would be suited so draw the
polygon we'll look at these details soon
and we also want to move the asteroid
move the asteroid and handle handle edge
of screen so we don't want them floating
off into space to e edge of screen good
now let's go back up to our where we
create our asteroids so we're going to
create a random number of sides so we
can achieve that by well we'll call make
a property called vert short for vertex
or vertices so Italy math.random times
will make you a constant called say math
roids vert now in order to achieve what
we want we want to reign in number of
sides but we don't want sides equal to 0
or something do we so that's the first
of all add one to this to increase our
maximum to what we expect so that'll be
just have roads verticals 10 so that'll
give us a number between 0 and 10 as I
said 0 is 0 sided polygon is no good so
off to add something to this how about
we add half the roids vert so that'll be
5 for example
we'll need to find the floor of a list
to make it an integer floor we don't
want 3.5 sides for example
so that'll if what rhoids verticals 10
that'll give us a random number between
0 and 10 plus half of 10 which is 5 so I
ran a number between 5 and 15 centered
around this number sounds good don't
need this semicolon again so let's go
create go ahead and create that
rhoids vert will equal 10 and this will
be the average number of vertices
vertices on each asteroid okay so head
down to our update function
so each asteroid will have a random
number of vertices all right down here
right there we go draw a path right so
to draw the path we need to context
begin path and then we want to move to
the first point so move to move to the
first XY location I'm thinking to save
us a little bit of time we should
probably get the properties grab all the
properties and put them into a variables
here so get the asteroid properties just
to save us a little bit of typing I
think so we'll set up some variables
here X Y the radius the angle and the
number of vertices so X will equal roads
I dot X and then we can go ahead and do
the same for all our other things so Y
will be the Royds I write roads why I
should say the radius will be dot R the
angle will be dot a and the number of
vertices will be vert
okay so our initial point will be the X
location the center of the asteroid plus
the radius multiplied by the cosine the
cosine of the angle similarly the Y
component will be the sine radius times
the sine of the angle now to draw the
polygon
we'll have to loop over the number of
vertices so we can set up a new variable
to say J will equal zero J is less than
the number of vertices J plus plus and
we want to draw a line to each corner of
the polygon so context line to line two
so in a similar way to what we've done
above so X plus the radius times the
cosine of the angle but we'll have to
modify it based on which vertices which
vertex we're currently at so we can do
that by modifying this by J times three
and 60° math.pi times two but we'll have
to divide that by the number of vertices
right so that'll for example if there
was two inverter C's then this will
modify the angle by 36 degrees each time
which is what we want do the same thing
for y except that we need to change it
to sign after that we'll have to close
the path and draw it by just going
context stroke stroke
all right it's quick review of our code
just make sure there's no glaring
mistakes so we're going to create the
asteroid belt that should be a zero not
an O divided by that mouthful right if I
miss the can that should probably cans
not canvas right and now push some new
asteroids
up some properties I think that's pretty
good
and then we'll draw them down in the
update function down here let's try it
there we go
so we got some randomly positioned
randomly positioned polygons from size 5
so 5 sides to 15 sides I guess let's see
if we get a 5 side on there's a 7 just
to make there we go there's a Pentagon
awesome but as I said mentioned earlier
probably is that we don't want the
asteroids to appear on the player like
that so let's go ahead and fix that up
now we can do that up in our create
asteroids method create asteroid belt
here we'll have to do something here we
can handle this using a do-while loop so
do all of that while some condition now
what is the condition we want to buffer
don't read between the asteroid and the
ship so how about we create a function
called distance or dist
between points distance between points
and we're going to pass each of the
coordinates so the ship's location ship
X ship Y and the potential asteroid
location X Y now as long as that is less
than some buffer so it will just say the
roids space it on the roids size say
times 2 plus the radius of the ship as
long as less than that if it's less than
that we'll keep creating new random
points until it's not less than that so
let's go ahead and create this function
distance between points now we'll be
passing we're passing the points so x1
y1 x2 y2 all right so we're going to
return now if you know your Cartesian
coordinate system it's the square root
of the square
so math power the square of X 2 minus X
1 X 2 minus X 1 squared plus similar
thing with the Y component Y power y 2
minus y 1 squared that should be ok
let's try it it's hard to tell because
there's only three there's only three
roids how but we bump this up to say 300
there we go see that buffer zone so
they're being randomly placed but
they're not being randomly placed within
our buffer zone you could adjust that to
suit your taste how pretty with that
back to three all right that's that
handled okay so what about the shape of
these asteroids so just have a look at
them they're perfect polygons aren't
they not exactly very asteroid looking
so let's add some jaggedness to this so
how about we go up and create a constant
called roids jag and let's define that
to be a number between zero and point
one so let's pick another zero point
four this is the jaggedness of the
asteroids and let's define that as zero
equals none one equals lots okay now
where we create our asteroids so in new
asteroid let's create some variable sum
property which modifies the vertex
location
so each vertice will be one radius away
from the center but we create say an
offset so offs that'll do offsets is
just going to be an array and let's set
up the array here so create the create
the vertex offsets
arrey okay so it'll be based on the size
of the the number of vertices over I
will equal zero I is less than the riod
dot vert I plus plus so we'll loop
through for each vertex and create a
random sort of multiplier to the radius
okay so the maximum we'd want is the is
so the minimum we'd want is zero and the
maximum may be say two two times the
radius so that would be in the worst the
most extreme situation so yeah let's go
roid dot offsets push we're going to
push a random number random number based
off the jag so the roids jaggedness and
how we're going to handle that if it's
there so it's zero we want nothing we
just want to be all of this to equal one
if it's one it could potentially equal
zero to two so how many times despite
two and add one minus the roids
jaggedness now does that work let's have
a think about this so if it was zero 0
times 2 is 0 so it would be 0 plus 1
minus 0 1 okay that works fine so
there'd be no jaggedness if it was
maximum so if this equaled 1 we'd have 1
times 2 is 2 so 0 to 2 plus 1 minus 1 is
0 so be a number random multiplier
between 0 & 2
that sounds good how about in the middle
point 5 I have point 5 times 2 is 1 so 0
to 1 plus 1 minus 0.5 that would be a
random number between 0.5 and 1 point 5
sounds good
so we're populating this offsets here
great how do we handle that let's go
down to the asteroids here all we have
to do is multiply this radius here by
that offset so how about we create up
here
that should be verse doesn't really
matter it's obviously declaring it
anyway offs offs will equal roids I
office okay now the first point is going
to be so this will be the radius times
the off it'll be the first position
won't it the offs zero so whatever that
random multiplier is it's going to
multiply the radius by it and we're
going to do a similar thing here now how
about here
well it's not going to be zero it's
going to be J isn't it it's going to be
J in here but we've already done J
equals zero up here so we don't how
about we start one here so we'll start J
at one yeah that should work now let's
have a look at see what that looks like
hmm looking promising actually it's
looking pretty good looking very good
okay I think we solved it so let's go
test different very different values of
jaggedness say point let's do the
extreme so one what will that look like
yes you can see here they're very jagged
okay
now if it's zero there should be no
jaggedness it should be a perfect
polygon yep and then as you add more
jaggedness so point one should be a
little bit jagged yeah just a little bit
depends what shapes you want in your ah
I'm gonna go stick with 0.4 that looks
pretty good to me
awesome now all we have to do now is
move these things get them moving go
down to where we had where are we draw
the polygon close move the asteroids so
that'll just be roids
I dot X plus equals roids I dot X V
that's the velocity in the X Direction
similar for the y direction let's just
oops this is probably one of the easier
parts let's just check to make sure
they're moving yeah so they're going at
random speeds we could probably bump up
the number of bump up the number of
roids to begin with just to see if set
in yeah they're definitely going at
different speeds different directions
cool and the color is quite nice isn't
it awesome just put that back two three
we also want to handle what happens when
they go off the edge of the screen so
currently if you look at these asteroids
they go off the screen and then they
disappear forever let's bring them back
onto the other side of the screen handle
the edge of the screen so if if roids I
dot X if that's less than 0 minus roids
i dot radius if it's less than zero then
it's gone off the left of the screen so
we want to set roids eye X to equal the
canvas width plus the roids eye radius
yeah
else it's not really an else it's
probably more of an else if else if this
situation roids
Lloyd's X is greater than the camera's
wits plus plus its radius then we want
to set
so this roids X will equal that that's
for the X direction do a similar thing
for the Y direction so why why why why
except it'll be based on height won't it
height let's give that a go okay going
off-screen this right one here will it
pop back on yeah there it is over there
there's one going off the bottom screen
is it coming back on yeah there it is so
they're coming back on we can bump up
the number of asteroids just to get a
good feeling for it
Roy it's number 10 there we go so one
went off the top up there once again off
the side here good I think that's
looking good so that's the end of
today's tutorial next time we'll focus
on collision detection and making this
row making the ship blow up when it hits
a when it hits an asteroid
so in this tutorial we're going to allow
the ship to crash into the asteroids by
using collision detection so you can go
ahead and download this code I'll have
it in the link below so let's go ahead
and create a flag called show bounding
now this is just this show Center dot I
created off-camera it's just a way for
us to not delete code or not comment out
code so we can always allow our
development settings to stay there so
for example show Center dot if shows in
a dot draw the center dot but we don't
want that normally during gameplay so
it's a nice convenient way to turn that
off and we can do the same thing with
our bounding boxes for our bounding
circles so said that's a true to begin
with show or hide collision bounding so
how are we going to represent our
collision detection what shapes are we
going to use for our bounding boxes well
take a look at the game I'm thinking the
simplest way is probably to just use a
circle for everything so a ship would be
represented with a circle and each
asteroid would be represented with a
circle it's not exact but it's a close
approximation and I think it will do for
such a high speed simple game so let's
go ahead and use circles so let's draw
our circle down in the update function
where we draw our ship hmmm so draw the
triangular ship just after we do that we
will say if show bounding so if our
bounding flag is on we want to set the
color so the stroke style well II will
say lime pick a color that you stands
out we want to begin a path because
that's how we do a circle and context
arc now we need a center point which is
going to be the center of the ship so
ship dot X to ship that lie and then
we're going to use the ship's radius the
start angle is zero the end angle is 360
degrees which just is math pi times two
in radians
and false for that final flag finally we
just need to draw the stroke itself
let's test that out yeah so we've got a
bounding circle around our ship
similarly we want to do the same thing
for each asteroid so good and to where
we draw the asteroids just after we draw
it before we move it paste that in there
but instead of ship dot X we just want X
because we've already declared X to be
the ship SEC sorry the asteroids X Y and
our let's test that out yep so each
asteroids got a circle around it the
only problems that the color of the
circles gone through to the asteroid we
can fix that up by just changing where
we set the color of the asteroid so
currently we're setting it before the
for loop just paste that into the start
at the start of the for loop so it will
do it every iteration give that a go
great so what's our goal our goal is
when the circle of the ship touches the
circle of any of the asteroids the ship
will blow up so first things first I
think we'll need to take out the moving
of the asteroid so how about we just
stick to our drawing sorry our update
function we're drawing the ship and
we're drawing the asteroids let's take
out the movement and put it elsewhere so
here we're rotating the ship and moving
the ship so we'll place the asteroid
stuff after that so move the asteroid
this is we'll have to do another for
loop here for VAR I equals 0
eyes less than roids dot length I plus
plus
and just encapsulate that and test it to
make sure that we haven't broken
anything yep it's still working so the
air asteroids are still moving next we
want to check for collisions for
asteroid collisions so just copy this
first line of the for loop now before we
start moving everything so before we
start rotating the ship let's check for
asteroid collisions right so we're gonna
cycle through every asteroid and check
whether the distance between so this is
a function we made before distance
between points so the ships x-value the
ship's y-value and the asteroid so roids
I dot X and the roids I dot y so if the
distance between the individual asteroid
and the ship is greater so is less than
the ship's radius plus the rhoids radius
so the asteroids radius that means the
circles have overlapped what will we do
there how about we just call a function
called explode ship which we haven't
made at the moment so if we if we run
this now it should try to call this
function and break it should stop
working let's try it right so we've got
the ship let's try to crash into an
asteroid yeah it's broken so as soon as
those two circles met the it's tried to
call that function and broken good it
means it's working
okay let's create that function explode
ship first of all just copy this text
sorry this code here to create a circle
so up in this function so function
explode ship let's just create a circle
let's create a filled circle so it's an
obvious sort of graphical indication
that the collision detection is working
so create a fill style the same color
lime the X&Y coordinate will be the x
and y of the ship as well as the radius
of the ship
and we'll also call the fill method so
we'll call it B calling a fill and a
stroke let's test that so when we
collide into a asteroid come on
asteroids where are you there's one down
there we should change to a filled
circle awesome and when we leave we're
no longer filled good that means our
detection our collision detection is
working very well great okay what do we
Altima want to do here I'm thinking we
should set so let's cut this I'm
thinking we should set some property of
the ship let's call it say explode time
explode time and that will equal say
it's equivalent to the number of frames
left in the explosion
so that'll equal some constant so ship
explode say duration x so that'll be in
seconds x the frame rate to get the
number of frames because we want an
integer we should probably find the
settler say steel will find the bull
roundup in effect
okay so let's create this ship explode
duration constant ship explode duration
and it'll be in seconds so just choose a
number point 3 so this will be the
duration of the ship's explosion right
where we set up the ship initially we'll
have to give that and explode what do we
call it explode time and it'll be zero
in it that means will be zero frames
left of exploding and that's how we're
going to detect whether the ship is
exploding or not when explode time
equals zero its exploding so go down to
the update function how about the first
thing we do dis create a variable so
gonna be a boolean called exploding and
that'll equal ship dot explode time
equals zero no greater than zero so if
the chips explode time is greater than
zero that means the ship is exploding
okay so where will we draw this
explosion I'm thinking instead of
drawing the ship will draw the explosion
in its place so if not exploding so if
not exploding will draw the ship else
will draw the explosion what will the
explosion look like well I'm thinking
just some circles to keep it simple so
he'll copy and paste this code here but
we'll use filled circles so fill style
will equal read the ship's radius habit
we try times by 1.5 say and we need to
call the fill method how about we work
in words so we'll start with the outer
circle which is red and then we'll make
say three more red orange yellow and say
white for the middle we'll change these
radius percentages habit will decrement
it by 0.3 each time so there's 0.9 here
and 0.6 for the inner circle let's take
a look at that crash into a asteroid
it's looking okay maybe a bit bigger in
the middle and maybe we need another
ring on the outside I think and we'll
get rid of that bounding so I'll turn
that to false show bounding explosion
where are you here we go so what did I
say maybe make it a little bit less in
the middle so reduce that by point one
so that'll be one point one that'll be
one point four
and we'll also do one more ring on the
outside a bit of a darker red I assumed
dark red is a HTML color and change that
to 1.7 let's see what that looks like so
there's no bounding circles now let's
crash yeah that's pretty good I reckon
we'll stick with that one if you go back
to our game just restart that you'll
notice that when we crash into an
asteroid we can continue moving and our
frustr is still working that's not what
you want we kind of want to stop in
place and just explode okay so let's fix
that now so let's go up to our thruster
so just up here draw the thruster we
don't want to do that when we're
exploding
so if exploding that should be if not
exploding if we're not exploding then
we're happy to draw the thruster okay
let's try that out quickly yep so
there's no thruster coming out the side
or the rear of the explosion that's good
also we don't want to be moving the ship
so go down to where we moved our ship
here we go rotate the ship move the ship
we also don't want to be checking for
asteroid collisions so we can include
that in here so if not exploding we
don't want to rotate we don't want to
move and we don't want to check for
collisions let's test that so I'm
pushing forward bang I'm still pushing
forward trying to turn nothing's
happening
great so what happens when the ship is
exploding well we can handle that here
in else so else the ship is exploding we
want to take the duration of the
explosion into consideration so we can
do that by ship not explode time - - so
we'll reduce the amount of time left on
the explosion now what happens when that
reaches zero so if ship
explode time equals zero that means we
should end the explosion so how about we
create a new ship
so ship will equal new ship now new ship
is just a method I'm just creating well
we'll go create that now so new ship
now all that we'll do is basically this
so where we set up the initial space
ship I'll just cut that we can change
that to nip good mmm go down to where we
just after new asteroid will create you
ship function new ship and what does it
do it just returns that thing that we
had copied okay let's test that
okay so we'll fly our ship into an
asteroid Bane and we're resetting now
there is one issue with this what if the
asteroid is coming towards our initial
restart position like this bang bang
bang bang bang that's no good is it how
the original game handles this is by
allowing the player to blink for a few
seconds before they start the game and
this prevents any explosions from
occurring so like an invulnerability or
an invincibility or something similar so
let's implement something like that
we'll need to go up the top and set some
parameters here so how about we have an
invisibility duration or invulnerability
duration we'll set that to say three
seconds duration of the ships
invisibility in seconds and we also
wanna know how long is each individual
blink during that invisibility so we'll
call that say ship blink duration and it
can equal say 0.1 second so 0.1 second
it will stay off point one second all
turned back on duration of the ship's
blink during in vis
the bility in seconds okay go down to
where we create our shear well they need
to set up a couple of properties here so
we'll have one called so blink time
that'll be the roundups and math.ceil
it'll be equal to the ship
blink duration times the frame rate so
the frame rates 30 right link duration
is 0.1 so there'll be three frames every
third frame it'll blink on and off and
we'll also want to have the blink number
keep track of the blink number so that
will be equal to the ship invisibility
duration sets three seconds divided by
it ships blink duration so that'll be a
total of three divided by point one so
30 blinks so they'll be 15 off and 15 on
that sounds good so just down below in
our update function let's create another
variable called blink on say blink on
and that will be equal to well have
let's say that when the blink number is
even then we'll be blinking on when it's
odd will be blinking off so we can
handle that by using so ship thought
blink num mod to when that equals zero
so when the remainder of dividing that
by two equals zero that means it's an
even number else it's an odd number
right so where we draw our ship so if
not exploding inside there so if blink
is on if blink on we want to draw the
ship how about underneath that we handle
the situation just say handle blink
handle blinking
so we needed so if the ship blink number
is greater than zero that means we have
to do something here how about we reduce
the blink time so that's what's keeping
track of the blink duration so blink
ship dot blink time - - and we also want
to reduce the blink numb blink numb
reduce the blink numb so that's if ship
got blink time equals zero if that
equals zero then we want to well we have
to reset that don't we so reship got
blink time will equal math dot seal
rounding up the ship's blink duration
times the frame rate and we'll also
decrement the blink numb so ship dot
bling numb - - hopefully that should
work okay
it's a blinky and it lasted a number of
seconds let's see if that works after we
smash one two three yeah
good it seems to working the only thing
we haven't done is that we haven't
incorporated in vulnerability yet have
we we haven't changed the collision we
haven't included blinking the collision
control so let's deal with that now so
let's go down to where we handle
collision control maybe the asteroids
here we go so check for asteroid
collisions so we only want to do that if
the ships blink numb equals zero so that
means we're not currently blinking if
the ships blink numb equals zero
we'll handle collisions so if it doesn't
equal zero it'll ignore collisions it'll
make us invulnerable let's test that
we'll probably need to
bump up the number of asteroids a bit so
as Roy num lets make 30 okay so we're
invading invulnerable bang yep
bang so we're about while we're blinking
oops let's see if I can not hit one good
so I'm not just blinking all the time
bang now I'm invulnerable one thing I
notice is that our thruster is still not
blinking we should probably make that
blink let's go back and fix that so just
reduce that back down to 3 head down to
where we draw our thruster so draw the
thruster if not exploding and blink on
then we'll draw the thruster let's test
it yep so we our thruster is blinking as
well let's crash into an asteroid bang
are we still invulnerable yes just
smashing Iran yep everything looks to be
good so that's the end of today's
tutorial so we've looked at collision
control and blowing up the ship next
we'll focus on shooting so using the
laser of the ship by pressing the
spacebar and blowing up asteroids
currently our code allows us to fly ship
around and smash into asteroids but
apart from that we can't do anything
else so in this tutorial we're going to
create a laser effect so we'll be able
to press the spacebar and shoot these
pesky asteroids so you can go ahead and
download this code if you don't already
have it
first of all let's create some constants
how about we create one called
laser max so that'll be the maximum
number of lasers on screen at once we'll
set that to say 10 to begin with so
that'll be maximum number of lasers on
screen at once and we'll also have say
the laser speed we'll need to know how
fast these little things travel we'll
put that in say pixels per second speed
of lasers in pixels second so how will
we detect when this spacebar is pressed
well we can go down to where we detect
our other key presses so in the key down
method just copy and paste one of those
cases there the key code for spacebar is
32 so let's label that space bar and mob
let do it we'll shoot the laser so let's
just create a function name here shoot
laser there we go we'll implement that
after now in the key up method so when
the spacebar is released what should we
do well I'm thinking when we press the
spacebar we should lock the shooting so
you can only shoot once per press so
here we should allow shooting again so
when when we release the spacebar let's
allow shooting so we could probably
handle that with a property on the ship
called say can shoot and we'll set it to
true here can shoot equals true let's go
down and add that to the ship now so in
the new ship method
can shoot it should start off is true
shouldn't it we want to allow shooting
to begin with we'll also need to keep
track of our lasers so they can be kept
kept track of here in the ship and it's
just an empty array to begin with so
just below let's create our shoot laser
function so function shoot laser in that
we want to create the laser object and
we also want to prevent further shooting
that's fairly simple to manage just go
ship dot can shoot equals false
now before we add a new laser object we
want to check a couple of things so if
one the ship can shoot so if the ship
can shoot and the ship lasers array the
length of that is less than our laser
max right if both of those conditions
are true we can add we can safely add a
new laser so add a new laser we just go
ship got lasers push well want to put
this in curly braces because it's an
object that will be creating here we'll
need to know the x coordinate and the y
coordinate we will be shooting from I
think we'll be shooting from the nose of
the ship so from the nose of the ship
and we have used that code before it's
need to go down to where we draw our
ship where is it here it is nose of the
ship so just copy both of those there
the x and y coordinates paste them in
there that'll be the Y just need a comma
there we'll also need to know the X
velocity which will be based on the
laser
speed times by the cosine of the ship's
angle
lots of trigonometry in this / the frame
rate to get pixels per frame and
similarly for the Y velocity except that
it'll be the sign of the ships angle so
let's go down and draw our lasers we can
do that after we've drawn our ship so
just after the collision circles there
in the center dot so draw the lasers so
after user for loop var I equals 0 I is
less than the ship
lasers dot length i plus plus we'll have
to set the context fill car a fuel style
I'm thinking will draw small circles to
represent the lasers now take some of
these colors out before ourselves going
to be used salmon for the laser color
it's quite nice we'll need to begin the
path to draw a small circle and we'll
need to use the arc method arc and we
need to know the X so it'll be the ship
lasers I dot X the ship lasers i dot y
the radius will base that off the size
of the ship so we're gonna price say
divided by fifteen the start angle is
just zero the end angle is math Pied
Piper times two which is effectively 360
degrees the final flag doesn't matter
and we'll need to draw our we'll need to
call the context fill method to draw
this let's just test that now that
shouldn't move at this stage cool so
they're appearing at the nose of the
ship that's promising and we can only
should only be able to do ten of them
yeah
greats
so let's go down and move the lasers so
just after we move the ship move the
lasers again we'll need to use a
for-loop so for I equals zero I is less
than the ship lasers length I plus plus
so what we will need to do here is just
go ship dot lasers I the x position plus
equals ship dot lasers I X V which is
the velocity in the X direction
similarly for the Y we just need to
modify it by Y V let's test that so
shooting lasers not quite going in the
direction we want I see the problem one
of the guests the Y so back up where we
shoot our lasers should shoot lasers I
see the Y V needs to have a negative
there because negative is upwards on the
screen let's give that a go great now
the only issue is that once we run out
of those ten shots there's no more there
forever flying off into space so let's
fix that up now the first thing we can
do is handle the edge of screen so just
go down to where we move our laser do
all the lasers move the lasers handle
edge of screen so we've done this a fair
few times with other objects it's all we
need to do say if let's copy this like a
bit easier for me if the ship so the
lasers exposition is less than zero then
we just want to set it to equal the
canvas width
else if the lasers exposition is greater
than the canvas width then we want to
set it to zero copy all that we'll do
the same sort of thing for the Y
position the Y position the why-why-why
and instead the width we'll use the
height okay let's give that a go
shooting some lasers I can I shoot 10
and as you can see they forever fly
around and around the screen so what
we'll probably need to do is set some
maximum distance they can travel and
then they kind of fizzle out or just
dissipate or whatever so let's do that
now firstly let's go all the way up the
top and create a constant called say
laser distance or just laser disk so
let's make it a fraction of screen width
so choose an infraction na- 8.6 and well
cool we'll define this as max distance
laser can travel as fraction of screen
width also need to set up a property on
the laser so go down to shoot laser and
just here we'll add a property called
dist distance traveled and we'll set it
started at 0 so let's head on down to
where we move our laser move the laser
just after where we update its position
let's calculate calculate the distance
traveled
so [ __ ] thought lasers i dot distance
plus equals now we'll have to use
Pythagoras theorem here so a squared
plus B squared equals C squared so the
square root of the square so math power
of this here the X velocity component
that's what we're adding each time so
the power of that sorry
square of that plus math power the
square of the Y velocity all Square
rooted should give us distance and what
do we need to do with that distance well
before we move our ship so this will be
moved it's not that ship is it move the
laser will want to check distance
traveled and we want to delete the laser
if this happens don't we so if ship dot
laser distance is greater than the laser
distance now that's as a percentage of
as a fraction so times the canvas width
[Music]
if it's greater than that
then that means it's gone far enough and
we want to delete it there's a couple of
ways we can delete from an array I'll be
using the splice command so ship lasers
splice and splices takes the start
number which is going to be I and the
delete count which is just one we just
want to delete one thing now the issue
with splice is that it permanently
changes the size of this array meaning
our for loop will have some problems so
we can get around this but instead of
going forwards in the loop we'll go
backwards so far I will equal
the length of the array minus one and
we'll go until I is greater than or
equal to zero and instead of
incrementing will decrement so I minus
minus so that'll be removed so we won't
want to continue in this we won't want
to try to move the laser because it
won't be there so we'll hit it will
write the continued command now all that
does it skips over the rest of this and
goes to the next iteration of the for
loop so that should be okay let's give
it a go shooting lasers yep they are not
going on forever how about we change it
to something a bit smaller so the laser
distance will change to something a bit
smaller say 0.2 just so we can get a
real good feel for it shoot some lasers
awesome so we can unlimitedly shoot
these lasers because they destroying
themselves after they reach point 2 of
screen width let's just change that back
to 0.6 now we need to detect when the
lasers actually strike the asteroids so
head down to our update function just
under where we draw our lasers draw the
lasers so we'd like to detect laser hits
on asteroids right I'm thinking we'll
probably need to use some variables here
just to make it a bit cleaner so we'll
have the asteroid X the asteroid y-yes
droid ah the laser X and the laser Y so
we'll need to do a full loop backwards
again because we'll be removing
asteroids so we'll have I will equal
roads dot length minus 1 I is greater
than or equal to 0 I - - rights having
grabbed the properties of the grab the
asteroid
properties so a X will equal rides roids
I dot X similarly for the other ones so
a y the asteroids Y will be that and the
asteroids radius will be that okay now
we can loop over loop over the lasers
yeah it's a lot to work go backwards
with this one as well because we'll be
removing the laser after it strikes the
asteroid what is a different variable J
so J will equal the ship got lasers dot
length minus 1 J is greater than or
equal to 0 J minus minus let's grab the
laser properties so L X will equal ship
lasers J dot X and the ly the laser Y
will be just the dot y1 so we've got all
the properties now now we need to detect
when detect hits will say detect hits so
what happens how can we determine that
well must use a condition so if the
distance between points that's one of
the functions we made earlier on so the
x1 y1 is the asteroid X the asteroid Y
x2 is the laser X and the laser Y now if
the distance between the asteroid and
the laser is less than the asteroids
radius then we've got ourselves a hit we
don't need to worry about the radius of
the laser it's too insignificant it's
only small so that's a hit now what do
we want to do here well we want to
remove the laser
so that'll be done with a splice command
so we can go ship dot lasers J sorry
lasers dot splice and in brackets we can
go J comma one and we also want to
remove the asteroid well there's more we
want to do but this is just a temporary
placeholder so we'll go roid roids dot
splice I comma one so that should remove
the laser remove the asteroid and we
don't need to continue cycling through
this for loop once the lays one once
we've detected a laser striking the
asteroid and it's destroyed we can break
this break let's give that a go right so
there's some asteroids that shoot one
good it's disappearing there's another
one bang-bang now in the original game
when you shoot one of these big
asteroids it actually breaks into two
medium sized asteroids and then when you
shoot a medium-sized asteroid it breaks
into two smaller asteroids and then
finally when you shoot a small asteroid
it's dead it's completely dead so we'll
do the same sort of functionality I'm
thinking we should have a method call
here say destroy asteroid now the reason
being we'll pass its index the reason
being is that there's also another
situation that we can destroy an
asteroid that's if we're a mouse ship
into an asteroid it also gets destroyed
kamikaze pilot or something now if we go
to our new where we create the asteroid
so new asteroid because we're going to
have various sizes I'm thinking that
we'll need to pass the radius in here
alright so we have to find out where
we're calling this so far and update it
there's a new asteroid
we'll pass that instead I'd like to keep
these as integers because we'll be using
the mask to compare what's to figure out
what size the asteroids are so we'll
just do a math seal there because this
riod size is we don't know what that
could be somebody could set it to 77
right so there could be a fraction there
good now let's create the destroy
asteroid function now it will take the
index won't it that's what we passed
earlier destroy asteroid let's grab some
of the properties first so the x value
will equal the roids index that's index
being passed dot X and we'll grab the Y
component and we'll also grab the what
else do we need to know the radius I
think so of course we need to know the
radius because we need to split the
asteroid into if necessary and bring
only the bigger ones need to be split
necessary so if the radius equals so if
e radius of the asteroid being hit is
equal to the basically this that means
it's the original size the biggest size
if it equals that we need to split it
into two so what how we can do that
let's just go roids which new asteroid
new asteroid and it requires X Y and R
so the X will be equal to the same I'll
just set it to the same point so X the Y
will be the same the radius will be half
the size so we'll divide by four instead
of dividing by two okay and we want to
do that twice because they're split into
two now naturally because we're calling
this new asteroid method they'll also
have random velocities and so on so
we'll be fine else if ah
equals now if it equals this here that
means some medium one that's been that's
been hit if it equals that we want to do
a similar sort of thing so I'll just
copy all that but we want to break it
into even smaller pieces so divide by
eight at the same location and finally
destroy the asteroid so the original
asteroid that's been split that's just
where we can go Rhodes split splice
Royds splice now the start number is the
index and we just want to remove one
destroy index we also want to call this
don't really let's call that where our
ship smashes into something draw the
lasers detect hits on the asteroids
check for asteroid collisions we're not
exploding yep so when we explode the
ship we also want to destroy the
asteroid now which number asteroid
it'll be equal to I here I let's give it
a go hopefully it'll work so first of
all where's a asteroid there's well and
shoot it great it's splitting into two
the media ones splitting into smaller
ones now how about the smaller ones yep
they gain destroyed awesome amazing we
got that right first time around so it
seems to be working really well except
that we see the chest whether ramming
one of them will destroy it bang it did
now we'll just split the two if I Ram it
awesome tripe with a bigger one cool
there's just one issue that I've found
is that sometimes when you smash into it
you've destroyed more than one asteroid
especially when you're invincible like
that see that the reason for it is that
it's because it's it's cycling through
all of the asteroids so that's not right
all we need to do to fix that though is
break there so once our ship has
exploded it no longer continues
destroying asteroids try that one more
time so when you're invincible in the
inside something yeah that's better
that's really breaking that should break
into two yep awesome great there's just
one last thing I'd like to do in this
tutorial and that's to create some
graphical effect when the laser strikes
an asteroid so go right at the top will
set a duration for the laser explosion
so probably similar to this here ship
explode duration will have a laser
explode duration and the sensors say a
bit small I say 0.1 seconds the duration
of the lasers explosion in seconds right
so we'll have to give our laser a
property some called explode time so go
down to where we shoot the laser we'll
add the property called explode time and
it'll start off at zero so it means it's
not exploding there is no more explosion
remaining now go down to where we draw
the laser draw the lasers right so here
we want to say if ship lasers
I don't explode time if that equals zero
that means we're not exploding and we'll
just draw the normal laser beam laser
ball else this is will draw the
explosion draw the explosion
so it's just going to be some concentric
circles similar to what we did with our
ship when it collides with an asteroid
how about well let's see what we can do
here how about we based off the ship's
radius times by say 0.75 we'll do this a
few more times 0.5 and say 0.25 what
does have to be it's going to be a
smaller circle we'll just have three
concentric circles and the colors will
Lobby based off this one how about I
look some of these up before orange red
salmon and I think pink was a nice one
then we'll have to go down and set the
explosion time so we're we're detecting
the hits we don't want to remove the
laser at this point so we can go ahead
and delete that we want to destroy the
asteroid and activate the laser
explosion we can do that displace it
setting the property so ship lasers je
isn't it
yes J dot explode time that will equal
the the ceiling so the rounding rounding
up of the laser duration explode
duration times by the framerate we also
only want to run this if all of this if
all of that equals zero that means we're
not exploding and the distance meets
that requirement then we'll destroy the
asteroid and activate the laser
explosion finally we need to decrement
the explode time so go down to where we
move the lasers we also don't want the
laser to be moving when it's exploding
so here we can handle the explosion so
if ship lasers I if the explode time is
greater than zero
that means we're presently exploding
doesn't it else we want to move this
move the laser and calculate the
distance we don't need to do these
things when we're exploding so it will
decrement the explode time here so just
- - explode time - - and then we want to
destroy the laser after the duration is
up so if explode time equals zero then
we will ship lasers dot splice I comma
one so we'll just remove the eye phlaser
and what does he put us to use the
command continue here to prevent it from
continuous re to prevent it from going
over the remaining code it'll just jump
back to the full the next iteration of
the for loop hopefully that should work
let's take a look cool so we've got
ourselves a little blast radius it looks
pretty nice it's working let's see if we
can crash into a nice troit great thang
bang bang looking pretty good
so in this tutorial we're going to
implement new levels a live system might
give the player three lives and a game
over screen right you can go ahead and
download this code if you like from the
link below first of all let's go down
and create the skeleton of what we want
to do today so just where we set up our
ship androids and so on how about we
make it more generic set the game
parameters right so we'll declare our
variables we'll need a level current
game level we'll put our roads here as
well as our ship and we'll create a
method called say new game because we'll
have to call that after our game over so
all this stuff will put in another
method so go down create the new game
method new ship that'll do
function new game and it will create our
ship we don't need to set up the
asteroids because this they're created
inside this create asteroids method
we'll probably need a new level method
because after each level we'll call that
and inside the new level method we will
call that create asteroid belt so it can
just go straight after here function new
level and all you want to do currently
is create the asteroid belt just make
sure we haven't broken anything yeah
that's looking fine so inside the new
game method we'll want to set up our
level our initial level so I can start
at zero now what does level do well I'm
thinking probably inside our new
asteroid method we want to speed up we
want to make it make the asteroids here
incrementally faster so how about we
create a variable called level
all multiplier and that'll be equal to
one
initially plus say 0.1 times the level
so as the level increases this will
slowly go up this level multiplier and
we just want to multiply our base roid
speed by that level multiplier we will
do that in both the X and y direction
good and also where we create our
asteroid belt up the top here we want to
increase the number of asteroids so we
can just go where it says I is less than
roid num which is currently three we
want to add the level each time so at
level zero it won't affect it but at the
next level it'll add one and so on
currently we won't do anything if well
not obvious so we can test it by
changing that initial level back down in
the new game set to say level 10 yeah
you can see that there's more asteroids
and they're faster so if we set that to
level 20 there's lots and lots of
asteroids going very fast good to set
that back to zero now we need to
increment our level so when do we do
that well it's when the final asteroid
is destroyed isn't it
so go up to our destroy asteroid method
can you see that the final line is to
remove it from the array so all we have
to do is do a simple check there so a
new level when no when no more asteroids
so we can just use if roids dot length
equals zero then we want to increment
our level level plus plus we also want
to call a new level
simple enough let's give it a go I'll
just change the initial number of
asteroids so I don't have to shoot so
many Lloyd num will change it to 1 right
so when we destroy this asteroid we'd
expect it to go to a new level with two
asteroids where's that asteroid so I'm
not very good at this game there we go
and there's two new asteroids awesome
and we destroy both these asteroids
there should be three on the next level
and they'll be going slowly faster
they'll be hard to notice but that's
okay it's an incremental thing there we
go and there's three asteroids awesome
I'm thinking wouldn't it be nice if we
had some texts between levels showing
the current level number just to give
the player some indication and we
probably wanna make it fade out as the
as time progresses so how about we
create two variables down where we're
setting up our game variables one called
text and one called text alpha so alpha
will be the transparency component of
our text and we also need two constants
that we call the first one texts fade
time set that to something a couple
seconds 2.5 seconds say and that will be
the text fade time in seconds and we'll
also want one called say text size
we'll put it in pixels choose a number
so 40 pixels this will be the text font
size in font size font height in pixels
right now we are we going to set these
up well probably at the start of the
level so we'll go down to new level new
game new level
so text will equal what we want to show
level plus the current level so it'll be
level Plus now room we're starting at
level equals zero we don't want to
display level zero so we'll add one to
this so that'll be level plus one and
the text alpha we want to start at full
opacity
so that'll equal one point 0 text alpha
taxi number between 0 transparent and
one open opaque so to draw the text
we'll want to go down to our update
function how about we draw the text last
so that it appears on top of everything
so after we draw our lasers I believe
draw the lasers just after that we'll
say draw the game text now we only want
to draw this when the text alpha is
greater than zero so text this probably
wouldn't matter if you didn't check for
this but we will so if text alpha is
greater or equal than zero then we want
to draw our text so how about we give it
a color fur so fuel style sorry
context dot fill style will be a color
now we want white but we also want to
set the Alpha component so to do that we
can go RGBA bracket now what's just 255
255 255 and after that we need that
alpha component so we can just add to
the string our text alpha and then we'll
also have to close that
the bracket that parentheses okay we'll
also want the font so the font will
equal well here we can add a whole bunch
of strings but you put the style have it
we just as an example puts small caps
we'll need the size of the font so we've
already decided that so text size now
that's in pixels so we'll have to put px
after it and we need the that's the type
of font so Dasia will put dejavu sans
mono i mean you can put arial there or
century new whatever your favorite font
is right now we'll need to draw the text
now so that'll be fill text fill text
command it requires a text string which
is just text the X will say it's halfway
across the screen so canvas canvas width
divided by 2 and the y component we
could put it in the middle of the screen
but then that'll be over our spaceship
so that's probably not good how about we
put it say 3/4 of the way down the
screen so canvas start height times 0.75
and finally we need to decrement our
alpha we want to slowly fade out so
that'll text alpha minus equals now it
starts at one point zero but we'll have
to divide that by our duration so texts
fade time and we'll have to take into
account the frame rate so divided by fps
and we'll probably have to bracket all
that so that it treats it as a single
thing let's give that a go
oops
level one well it's appearing and it's
disappearing just the location of its
not very good we just need to Center it
so we can do that by going context texts
is it text text the line the align will
be in the center and we can also align
it vertically by saying texts based
align equals middle I believe you can
look all these up let's give that a go
that one great so if we destroy this
asteroid will we get to level two and
will let's show the text my shooting
skills need improvement there we go
level two good I think that's enough of
a transition between levels next we'd
like to deal with the game lives so
we'll start with probably three lives
so that's create a constant to represent
that constant game lives will equal
three that's the classic number but you
could set it to five or seven or
whatever so starting number of lives and
will also need a variable to keep track
of current lives so I'll just call it
lives inside our new game method we can
initiate that soul iris will equal game
lives and also want to draw some
gathering some graphical representation
of these lives which is usually just the
ship itself in the top left corner so go
down to where we draw or probably just
after we draw the game text will draw
the lives so I need a for loop here so
var I equals 0 I is less than current
lives I plus plus
and we'll need to have to make a method
here say draw a ship because we already
have drawn our ship we don't want to
repeat the code here so we'll go ahead
and make that method find out where we
draw our ship first we draw here we go
so draw the triangular ship just this
code here will cut that now we'll need
to know separate X&Y location because
the ship moving around the screen isn't
it going to be the same X&Y location as
the lives and probably the angles
important so we can go draw ship
we haven't made this method there so I'm
just preparing it draw or ship say ship
dot X ship dot y and it's angle so XY
and the angle let's go ahead and create
that method now so just after disk
between points function draw ship now we
need an X component a Y component and an
angle and inside there just paste what
we had in on the clipboard I want to
update this to match the parameters
there so the line width for style that's
all good the x and y will just be the x
and y we don't need ship prefixing it so
just go ahead and delete all that X Y X
Y and also our angle so it's just going
to be a so we'll have to delete all the
ships before the A's a little bit of a
tedious process but well worth it also
at this time in the end there we go and
all we have to do now is update that new
inside the lives we just need to update
what X Y and a are so that should be ok
where we draw the actual ship now inside
lives we need an X component I'm
thinking it's going to be it's going to
start at the ship size so it'll it means
we'll have some sort of margin
but as we draw continue as we draw
across the screen we'll have to multiply
so we'll say I times will add I times
the ship size and we want some space
between each ship so probably just say
times by 1.2 that's the X component now
the y component will be I think just the
ship size doesn't have to be very much
of anything and the Alpha well it's
going to be 90 degrees now in radians 90
degrees is 0.5 times math.pi hopefully
that should work let's give it a yay
yeah that's looking pretty good so we
can see our lives up there there any
issues that nothing happens if we crash
if we crash oh I just want to crash
nothing happens because we haven't
implemented any code to decrement the
lives how about we reduce our lives
after the ship has exploded so just go
down a little bit where we reset the
ship after the explosion has finished
and here we can deck romantic lives so
lives - - and we may as well handle the
situation where lives equals zero so if
lives equals zero so that means we'll be
finished the game we can just call a
function called game over game over man
else we'll just do what was already
there the ship equals new ship so let's
go ahead and create an empty game over
function so just after explode ship
function game over and believe ourselves
that to do here to do game over
let's give that a go so if we crash in
this asteroid we expect the ship to
disappear yet after the explosion also
to make that look really nice how about
we change the color of the ship the life
ship that is as we strike the asteroid
just to give it a little bit of an a
graphical indication so to do that we
can go down to where we draw our lives
okay
draw the lives how about we create a
variable called say life color and we'll
set that dependent on the situation so
life color now when the ship is
exploding that means we've struck an
asteroid we want it to be a different
color but only the last life
the final life of this series so
exploding and I will equal lives minus
one that's that'll be the last one okay
if all that is true then let's set it to
say red else will set it to our normal
color white now how are we gonna pass
this we've already got this method draw
ship how about we give a fourth
parameter called color so we'll just
pass life color here now we're already
calling this elsewhere we could go ahead
and update you know the color for each
single call or we can just set a default
make it optional so go to our draw ship
function declaration we can say the
fourth parameter is a color and we can
just go equals white and what that does
if they don't provide a color it'll
automatically assign it as white it'll
be a default color and just down here we
can go color so let's give that a go so
hopefully we should get that first life
turning red when we strike this asteroid
great so it turns red and then
disappears a few moments later awesome
the last thing that we'd like to do in
this tutorial is implement the game over
function so how about we set a property
on the ship something to indicate that
it's no longer with us so how about ship
dead equals true we'll also want to set
some text to let the player know that
the game is over so game over at x
equals game over to make that work we'll
have to set the text alpha txt alpha
will equal 1.0 full opacity so we'll go
down to the new ship method and put in
that ded property so dead it'll start
the game as false we don't want them to
be dead to begin with let's give that a
go
so if we crash our ship three times
hopefully it'll show a game over a game
over message come on this is there we go
game over
the only thing is that we can still move
our ship around so that's no good is it
so the handle lap we can go up to our
event listeners so key down in the key
down method we want to say if ship dead
I've just returned so that means it
won't access any of the code below it
won't allow the user to do anything with
the keys and similarly in the key up
method just paste that in there right
also we don't really want to draw the
ship do we it should be dead so it
shouldn't be there any more so down in
our update function where we draw so the
asteroids are okay thrust the ship we
don't want to do that so if ship
thrusting and not ship dead so the ship
is alive will thrust and draw the
thruster draw the triangular ship so if
blink on and not ship dead will draw the
ship yeah the lasers are okay the game
text and all that's okay
the lives probably we don't want to
detect asteroid collisions anymore
so if ship link number equals zero and
not ship dead will detect asteroid hits
right let's give that a go
so crash your ship three times bang bang
and final one game over and I can't
control the ship there is no ship good
finally we'd like to reset the game
after some period of time how about
where we we're checking for texture so
that game over that game over message
will appear how about when that finishes
so we'll say else if ship is dead so
that means only when the text disappears
and the ship is dead so they'll be at
the end of game definitely we will say
new game new game let's give that a go
so smash into the asteroid bang smash
into the asteroid again bang and one
last time let's see what happens
game over the text disappears and we
start again at level one I think that's
pretty good and that'll do us for
today's tutorial so today we implemented
lives and resetting the game and level
up and so on increasing the difficulty
so it wouldn't be nice if we had a
scoring system so first of all let's
create some constants to represent how
many points each of our asteroids are
worth so Royd points large now in the
original game the large asteroids were
worth 20 points so we'll do the same
thing so this is the points scored for a
large asteroid so go ahead and copy that
a couple of times we also have medium
asteroids worth 50 points medium and we
also have small asteroids worth 100
points because they're the hardest to
hit we'll also need a variable so go
down to where we do declare our
variables called score that'll be our
current score and in this new game
method we'll want to reset that to zero
so put that in there score equals zero
now well we increment our score well
that occurs when we destroy an asteroid
doesn't it so go up to our destroy
asteroid method here we go and in where
we deal with our large asteroids we can
simply go score plus equals Lloyd Lloyd
points large will do a similar thing
inside the medium part of this statement
there we go score plus equal Rhoads
points medium and to handle small we can
just simply put it an else in here else
if it's not medium or not large we'll
add the small points now let's go down
and draw the score how about we put the
score in the top right hand corner of
the screen so just after we draw the
lives we can draw the score and let's
copy and paste some of this code up here
to draw text okay
so the text-align because we're on the
top right hand corner will change that
to write the base line can be middle
let's find the fill style we just need
plain white we don't need to change the
transparency the font we don't really
need small caps because it's only gonna
mean numbers text size pixels stage
revolutions mono is fine full text will
be filling the score the position will
be the canvas width but we do want a
slight margin so let's base it off our
lives margin so this is ship size so
we'll have ship size divided by two
because the ship is the center of the
chip ship size divided by 2 and the y
position will be the same exactly the
same as our ship so ship size let's test
that great we have a zero in the top
right hand corner that's promising let's
shoot one of these big ones we get 20
points that's good now a medium one oops
I shot another big one meteor one was
worth 50 and a small one should be worth
that should bring us to 190 ah 340 yep
that's working well now how about in the
middle the top middle of the screen we
put a high score so let's go ahead and
create a high score variable so head
back up the top and declare that
variable so just next to where we
declare the school we can also say score
high and inside our new game function
how about we initialize that score high
now ultimately we'd like to grab this
from somewhere like a saved location or
something but just to begin with let's
just set that to say 100 just to make
sure that it works we're really well we
handle the high school well up in our
destroyer asteroid method where we're
incrementing the score just after we do
that how about we do a check check high
score and that's simply going to be
condition so if the score is greater
than the high score
then we want to set the high score to
equal the score so score high will equal
score of course we'll need to draw that
so head back down to where we draw our
score draw the score we're going to do a
very similar thing with the highest
score draw the high school.the
text-align is going to be the center
because we want it in the top middle of
the screen text baseline is fine
the field styles white the font is but
we set this to a bit of a smaller font
so it doesn't take away from the current
score so we'll say time is by 0.75 just
put that in brackets otherwise the font
is the same the fill text will be the
score high the position will be the
middle of the screen so it'll be the
canvas width divided by two and it'll be
the same Y the same Y component let's
test that okay the one hundred it's not
exactly in the center of the screen is
it ah that's a spelling I've got the
Australian spelling not the American
spelling so Center with an ER let's just
double check that good I'm thinking
we'll probably need some sort of text
before that so maybe say I'm gonna use
the word best but you could use high or
top or whatever best plus the scroll
high let's see if that looks okay yeah
that looks okay now let's test to see if
it works so we'll be trying to get more
than 100 there we go so it's updating to
match the highest score obviously the
biggest issue is that when we reset this
it goes back to 100 we'll want it to
persist between browser sessions and
indefinitely basically so how can we do
that in the past we would have used
cookies but with html5 we can use local
storage local web storage so zoom back
up to our new game method where we set
the high score we can just write local
store
each dot get item now this gift item
function requires a key which is a
string like this is like a save key now
this only has to be unique within our
code it doesn't have to be unique across
all our software or whatever
I believe it's based on the URL so let's
create a constant prefix it with save
key save key score it's just a string we
can set colet's for example high score
and this will be the save key for local
storage of score of high score good go
back down to new you game put that in
there save key score let's see what that
does
right so when we haven't set it we
haven't said it yet
it comes back null so we'll have to
check for that so how about we pull that
down just underneath we do where we do
all this ship equals new ship
get the high score from local storage so
how about we create a storage string so
score string will equal all of that so
that's they'll string now if that string
if score string equals null then we want
to set the score too so set the high
score to equal zero that means they
haven't set a high score yet else we
want to set this high score to equal the
score string but because it's a string
will have to pass int so pass
Ince it requires a string which is just
the score stream hopefully that will
work let's give it a go
best a zero now although the score is
going up if we reset this it's not
storing it is it so we'll have to store
it somewhere to up where we increment
our score and test for the highest score
inside our destroy asteroids method so
check higher score here we can just set
it here
so we can go local storage set item we
need the key so the safe key safe key
score and the value will be the highest
score score high and hopefully that
should be everything right so we can't
have a best score of zero now we put the
best of twenty let's reset
yeah it's persisting so that should
persist between browser sessions between
games between everything so let's try
again 190 reset good and let's just to
make sure it's really working how about
we destroy our ship so we should have a
high score let's get a high score first
to 310 410 let's smash the ship a few
times for 65 60 and one more life left
610 so this should reset yep the scores
reset but our best score is still 610
great
so in this tutorial we're going to learn
how to add sound effects to our game and
music to some extent first of all go
ahead and download the sound files from
the link below I'll link to a zip file
it's important that you extract the
sounds directory to the same location as
the HTML file so I've just created a
folder called asteroids here put in both
the code and the sounds folder that's
important because we'll be referencing
this this directory inside our code so
inside the sounds directory there'll be
six sounds explode hit laser music high
music low and thrust I just used the
program audacity to create those but I
won't show you that here we can save
that for another tutorial so go ahead
and open our code so head down to where
we set up our variables so just before
we just have to lease out the canvas
let's set up sound effects so it's a
pretty simple process we just need to
create a variable let's prefix all our
variables with FX just to make it clear
so FX laser will equal new audio and
just inside there we'll need a string
for the source so that that'll be the
directory name sounds forward slash the
name of our files our laser dot m4a
now where do we want to call that where
do you want to play that sound well in
the laser method don't we so just head
down to where we press the spacebar
there should be a shoot laser method now
within that if condition all we have to
do is go FX laser dot play and because
it's a function call we'll need the
parentheses let's give that a go
okay a couple of problems first of all
it's quite loud so we can fix that up in
code and secondly when I push the
spacebar continuously it's not playing
every shot so watch again so although I
fired about 10 shots hit only play
about three or four times that's because
when the sound is playing and I call
another play method it won't play it
until it's finished so that's a problem
we can fix that up though so head back
up to where we create our audio
currently we're using this inbuilt
object or in built class called audio
how about we create our own custom
object called sound it will behave
exactly the same way we'll make sure
that it does go down and create that
let's create it just before our update
function so function sound the first
parameter will be the source now the
second parameter how about we create a
parameter that handles multiple
concurrent plays of our of our file so
let's call that Max streams and set its
default to one that's currently the
behavior we're experiencing now so when
we push the spacebar multiple times it
will only play one sound at a time and
also want to set the volume here now
volume takes a value between 0 & 1 so
how about we give it the default value
of 1 which is maximum volume or normal
volume so we'll have to create what to
keep track of which stream we're
currently playing so we can go this
start stream num equals 0 and we'll also
need to keep track of each stream so
that could be handled by an array for
example so this dot streams will equal
an empty array now to populate that
array we can just use a for loop so for
VAR i equals 0 I is less than max
streams I plus plus
so we can push to that array so this
start streams will have to use worth the
prefix all our variables here with this
so that it's referring to the objects
variable so this dot streams that push
now all we have to push is a new audio
objects a new audio and it takes the
source as an argument and we might as
well set the volume here so this dot
streams by dot volume volume will equal
volve that's what we're passing up here
that should set that up okay next we
need to implement the play function so
we can handle that by going this dot
play will equal function now we'll need
to increment the stream number so that
we cycle through each of the streams so
we can do that by going this dot stream
num will equal put this in brackets this
dot stream num plus 1 incrementing it
and find the modulus of the Max streams
I'll explain that soon so then we'll
call the so we'll find that our element
so this stop streams the element number
will be this start stream num this start
stream num dot play so that's just the
inbuilt play function so for example if
max streams equals 2 right so this
stream number 0 plus 1 is 1 1 modulus 2
is 1 so that will play the second
element of our streams that rain when
this function is called again so stream
number is currently 1 plus 1 is 2 2
modulus 2 is 0 it'll play the first
element of that array so in in essence
it will cycle through it will cycle
through playing each of those elements
each of the array elements as the player
function is
which is what we want so let's test that
so currently it's max streams equals one
it behaves exactly the same way so let's
head back up to where we call our
initial laser sound here we go and give
it some arguments so the number of
streams let's try two and the volume
let's turn it down a bit to say 0.5
right so the volume is okay now if I
play if I push the spacebar as fast as I
can
[Applause]
can you hear that it's only playing two
of them that's because our max streams
is two so what's a realistic number we
could set here how about five that's
probably fast enough so the player
wouldn't notice let's try it I think
that's pretty good
it looks pretty realistic to me awesome
next it's just a matter of implementing
our other sounds so let's copy that and
implement FX explode so that's where our
ship crashes into an asteroid just
update the source to sound slash explode
dot M for a well delete we won't use any
arguments here we'll just use the
default ones now we will recall FX
explode well explode ship comes to mind
where are we draw explode ship so just
after that FX explode dot play let's
give that a go so if we crash
yeah that sounds pretty good it's not
too loud I don't think great head back
up to our audio let's create another one
called FX heat so this is where our
laser strikes a asteroid and an asteroid
I should say sounds Hitler again we'll
just leave the default sound make sure
that actually we'll probably need to
increase the max streams the reason
being is that we could in theory hit a
lot of asteroids at the same time
because we're firing out lasers in quick
succession so how about we give that the
same number of max streams as the FX
laser and where will we call that well
probably when we destroy our asteroid
that's probably the right time to do it
so how about destroy the asteroid FX hit
dot play sorry that was just the
background asteroid ship blowing up
let's do that again
so when we shooter that yeah that sounds
alright so we're shooting out a lot of
lasers and we can hear some similar a
near hit sounds cool that sounds alright
I'm just thinking to stop us hearing
background explosions all the time let's
create a global flag called for example
sound on and will only allow sound when
that flag is set so there's an explosion
for example so if sound on then we will
play the sound if sound on then we will
play this sound let's go and create that
flag now
so just underwear we show for example
sentence I'm create a constant sound on
and that will be equal to false so let's
just run that make sure it's working yet
so those sounds will be heard while
we're programming next let's implement
the thruster sound so just where we're
creating the other sounds here let's go
FX thrust little sound slash thrust we
probably don't need any parameters here
now where will we call that well we play
that probably down in the update method
in the update method we thrust the [ __ ]
here we go thrust the ship so just up
near the top there
FX thrust dot play and when we release
the thruster key when we release the
forward arrow we'll probably need to
stop that thrust sound as well we don't
want it to continue onwards so how about
we in the else part of the condition we
go FX thrust dot stop so we'll have to
implement this method so FX thrust that
stops I go to our sound function and
create a new method called this dot stop
will equal function and all we'll do
there is call is call the inbuilt
pause function so this streams this
stream num not pause and we'll want to
reset back to the start of that stream
so we can do that by going this streams
this stream num dot current time equals
zero so that'll set the cursor or
whatever it is called back to the start
of that stream let's give that a go Oh
we'll have to turn on our sound first to
test this so sound on will equal true
that's working our thruster is working
cool good that's all our sound effects
done next let's create some music just
set the sound on back to false so that
we don't have to listen to explosions in
the background okay
now music I used the word music very
loosely so just under where we set up
the sound effects set up the music now
the music in asteroids the original game
was very pretty much just two times a
game but but but something like that
it's just kind of two different tones so
why don't we create a variable called
music and that will equal we'll have to
create a new object it's called music
for example and it will take the two
sounds so we'll have sounds music lobe
and the second parameter will be similar
sounds music hi so just the two sound
files that we have ones a low sort of
tone and ones a high tone let's go down
and create that object is just near
where we created our sound objects you
shoot laser just here function music so
we'll have source load and source high
so first of all let's declare our
variables so we'll have two sounds so
this dot sound load which will equal new
audio source low right similarly we'll
have this sound high which will equal
new audio source high
and we'll also need to keep track of
which sound are we currently playing so
we can just use a boolean for that so
this dot load will equal true that means
we'll set we'll start with the low sound
and we'll also need the speed of the
music the reason being is that as the
game progresses the speed of the music
increases so this start say tempo will
equal one point zero say and we'll
define that as seconds per beat we'll
also need to somehow count down that
tempo so we can have a create a variable
called this dot beat time we'll set it
to zero to begin with and that's
basically defined as the frames left
until next beat right we'll have to
create our play function so this dot
play equals function and what will it do
well if this if this stopped low we want
to play the low sound so sound sorry
this dot sound this sound lobe dot play
right and otherwise so else we want to
play the high sound this sound hi dot
play okay and we also want to switch
between those two so we can handle that
by going this stop low will equal not
this stott low so we're just switching
true to false and false to true okay
good we also need some way to count down
this tempo or such the beat time so how
about we create a function called this
start tick this dot TKE equals function
and this will be called every frame so
knowing that we can say if the so if
this dot beat time equals zero that
means it's counted down which it will
have immediately we want to play the
current sound so this dot play we also
want to reset the beat the beat time so
this dot beat time will equal the
ceiling so we want to keep it as a
integer math dot seal of the tempo so
this dot tempo multiplied by the
framerate so for example if the so the
current tempo is 1 the framerate is 30
so we'll have 30 ticks until the sound
is played so that's one second that
sounds good now else so it doesn't equal
zero we want to decrement it so this dot
beat time - - now where do we call this
tick well we need to call it in the
update function so just go down to the
update function up near the top tick the
music so we can just go music dot tick
now hopefully that will play our music
let's try okay it's not plain let's see
what's wrong let's head up to the top
and see if everything's okay where we
create our music music it was new music
sound music low okay I forgot to add the
extension to each of these music files
which is important but luckily the game
didn't break so I'd say it our code is
all correct let's give it a go right
that seems to be working
oh that reminds me we should probably
put in a global variable a global
constant music on
[Music]
and we can just go down to our music
method and in their play we can say if
music on then we'll do all of that good
so we've turned our music off now how
will we make the music go incrementally
faster as the game progresses well let's
head up to where we declare our music
variable and create a couple more
variables one called roids left and one
called
roids total and we'll find a ratio of
how many there are left to the total and
use that as a guide so just to now
create asteroid belt how about we set up
the roids total roids total will equal
the roid numb but remember each of those
big asteroids can be broken down into
two mediums and each of those mediums
can be broken down into two smalls so
we'll have four smalls plus two mediums
is six plus the original big one is
seven so roid num times seven will be
the total and we want to make roads left
equal to that roads left will equal the
roids total actually that should be the
roid numb plus the level shouldn't it
because you see down here the number of
asteroids is dependent on the level so
all of that times seven right that
should be okay so head down to our
destroy asteroid method and just after
we play the sound let's calculate the
ratio of remaining asteroids to
determine music tempo
the first thing we'll need to do is
roids left - - will decrement that and
then we'll we want to call a function on
music for example called set asteroid
ratio and then in there we can calculate
the ratio don't think I can think of is
if the ROI is left equals zero then so
roids left equals zero if that's true
well the ratio is going to be one we
want to reset the ratio to just one else
we will find the actual ratio to roids
left roids left / roids total so head
down to our music object music and we
want to create that method this set
asteroid ratio equals function we'll
need to have an argument have a
parameter here called ratio and this
will modify our tempo so this stop tempo
will equal the starting tempo - one
point zero - the ratio because when the
ratios for example point nine one - 0.9
is 0.1 one minus point one is 0.9 yes
that's fine the only thing I couldn't
see the only problem I can see here is
that this is going to get very small so
it'll become too small where we'll be
playing hundreds of beats per minute we
don't want that per second I should say
so let's multiply by that by some factor
0.75 times that right so that means when
the ratio is zero one one zero is 1.7
times 0.75 times one is 0.75 one minus
0.75 is 0.25 the fastest rate that we
can go as point two five that's four
beats per second okay well just need to
go turn on this music garden function
sorry the music on Flag set that to
truth
let's give it a go okay so that's one
beat per second let's destroy some of
these asteroids
yeah it's getting faster let's just play
until we get to the next level great
let's reset perfect let's just turn on
the sound to have one final play great
that's working well and that's the end
of this tutorial series I hope you've
enjoyed it just as much as I've enjoyed
making it so we've created a little
triangle that can fly around space using
the arrow keys we can press the spacebar
to shoot a laser we've created randomly
generated asteroids that float through
space we've added a scoring system with
a high school that saves to the local
storage and we've added sound in this
tutorial I'll post a link to the final
code in the description below feel free
to download it and have a play with it
yourself in for example change some of
these parameters or maybe you can add
some new functionality like power-ups
that float across the screen that your
ship can collect things like
invincibility or an extra life maybe a
split laser that shoots out multiple
laser blasts at once the only limit is
your imagination
and that's what programming is for me to
learn something new to create something
wonderful and to have a lot of fun along
the way
until next time talk to you then Cheers
[Music]